anti-vaccination protesters in london
have clashed with police while trying to
storm the old headquarters of the bbc
the broadcaster moved the vast majority
of its operations from the building
eight years ago
the demonstrators are furious about
government plans to start inoculating
teenagers in the bbc's role they allege
in promoting it
[Applause]
last week the government announced
coveted vaccines would be offered to all
16 and 17 year olds without needing
parental consent
it's believed that the national health
service will soon be instructed to start
giving the first doses to about 1.4
million teenagers
something the government says is
necessary in the face of the highly
contagious delta strain
and while the pfizer jab's also been
authorized for children aged 12 and
above
with a decision on whether to roll it
out to a younger age group has not yet
been
taken edward stashed reports from london
anti-vaccine protesters are on a mission
today they are taking
the streets of london going from one
media outlet to
another earlier today dozens upon dozens
of protesters tried to storm
the bbc television studios they were met
with mass
amounts of police officers and even
officers were armed with batons trying
to push them back
out of the entrance now today's uh
protest really started earlier today in
a nearby park they hadn't got
this uh mission in their mind at that
point but they decided at that point to
take to
the bbc studios to try and seize control
of it
well in relation to kobe because they
lied to the people basically they've
been beamed into our tv screens for the
last 15 months telling
lies bottom lines about the the death
rates the everything about kobe
whilst they are hiding pedophiles in the
bbc journalism is
based on two-sided story and our voices
are not heard that's what we're out here
to do today
it's the paid arm of the government to
put the government's word into
each of the households all of this comes
as the bbc
uh was forced to upgrade its security
protocols in the wake of freedom day
uh many people are arguing that
journalists were even being threatened
they are headed
uh towards the next media outlet place
they really are trying to come out in
force today they argue that these
vaccinations and passports are totally
ridiculous at this point in time we know
that the vaccination rollout program is
now going to
the under 80s and they say that that's a
direct
impeachment and infringement of freedom
and of course civil liberties as well
so today is not just about what's gone
before but what's to come in the future
too
you